(phone ringing)
- [Jen] Okay, so I took the
challenge just to catch you up,
I took the challenge.
You were on James Altucher's webcast,
you put it out there, and I took it.
Thank you for the kick in the butt.
It's been a total game-changer for me.
- Go figure.
- [Jen] Did you get a bunch of takers?
- Yes, I think we did.
I'm, like, actually scared
that I made that claim,
'cause I don't know
what's actually out there
of people that actually
deserve, I owe podcasts to.
So I'm gonna be scared for
this to show up on the vlog,
'cause now everyone's like,
"No, I took the challenge, too!"
You will represent
everybody, I'm gonna tell,
I'm much busier than James,
so I think James has to do the rest.
- [Jen] Okay, all right.
Well, I'll tell him that.
So, this led me to other things,
so after this, I was like,
"Wow, I really like this.
"I really like this medium."
I started doing flash briefings because
I found these guys that are basically like
the Libsyn of flash briefings,
where it takes one minute to get it up,
and then I read your chapter
in your book last night
in Crushing It all about,
you're calling it Voice-First.
Are you gonna use, is that term for, like,
flash briefings or own voice?
- That to me, look,
I think voice is kind
of the term I'm using
for podcasting and flash
briefings and Google
and Apple HomePod
and all the stuff that's
coming with voice.
- [Jen] And
to
think Pod is gonna let
us do briefings as well?
- Oh, yeah, I mean,
Home, Apple, and Google and
Amazon, all these people,
they're businesses to create a platform,
then let people build on top of it,
and then make a percentage of the action.
- [Jen] Who do you think's gonna win?
- No clue, could care less.
- [Jen] Okay, okay.
Let's see.
I also wanna ask you,
so, before this podcast,
I was very nervous,
and I was telling my friend,
"Like, I'm really nervous."
Then I said, "But I just have to remember
"that you're just a human being,
"and you put on your
pants one leg at a time,"
and I thought--
- I actually put my
pants two legs at a time.
I jump into my pants.
- [Jen] That's exactly what he said!
He was like, "I think he
jumps into his pants."
But, then, that got me thinking.
What do you do in the morning?
- I wake up, I grab my
phone, I go take a poop.
I make sure nothing's on fire
in the world, of my world.
You know, my biggest thing, look.
When you're the CEO of a
thing, it's your fault.
You're the last line of defense,
and so, that's the tough
spot and the fun spot.
Really, my morning is
really interesting, right?
Like, it's funny.
I can actually break down my morning.
The first thought that
runs through my mind is,
"Am I tired?"
Like, "Did I get the sleep that
I needed today to go hard?"
And the good news is,
I'm in a good place nine out of 10 times.
And then, the one time that I'm not,
that I'm like, "Oh, I
hope that my workout today
"is gonna wake me up or
make me feel better."
I love that workout now,
because whereas I used to not have that
and struggled through
the first couple hours,
and then my adrenaline would kick in,
now, usually, it's very rare for me
to be tired and go through a workout
and not be ready for the day, right?
But the biggest thing I
do is I check on fires.
I make sure nothing happened in London.
Don't forget, it's five
or six hours ahead of me,
so even when I wake up, it's six.
They're already well into their day,
and there could be a problem.
And overnight in LA, right?
If I go to sleep at midnight,
it's still only nine there.
Clients are still doing things.
I make sure there's no problems.
- [Jen] What are you doing right now?
- I'm rolling a bat on my lower left back
because I'm fixing my lower
left back muscle issues
and tissue quality,
and it's been a very weird
couple weeks for my team
watching me do all sorts of
weird things with my back.
But it's really good.
For everybody who's watching
right now, tissue quality,
I don't know if people know this.
Your brain protects you
from your most inefficient
physical attributes
and creates huge inefficiencies
by protecting you.
I've realized how limited
I was in my rotation
and bending and stretching.
And it's not about yoga and massages.
This is, like, real fuckin' tissue work.
You gotta really do it.
But it's been amazing, and I'm getting,
I've had a bad back for, like, 25 years,
and I'm this close, I'm in
the final pieces right now,
which is why I'm taking
this huge piece of wood,
it's a half a baseball bat,
and, like, ramming it into
my back, ramming my back.
- [Jen] Where did you get this idea?
Did someone recommend it to you,
or do you just thought,
"This looks like something
that would work?"
- No, my trainer, Jordan,
we roll on a hard ball, a lacrosse ball.
We have a stick.
This is not something he recommends,
this is just, I know this is working,
'cause I'm beating up the muscle.
I can feel what's happening.
It's amazing.
- [Jen] Back to your morning
routine for just a second.
Do you think that you're a natural,
okay, I wanna know how long it takes you
to reach for your phone,
and do you stay in bed
and read your tweets,
or are you up immediately,
and if you didn't have to get up early,
would you naturally be a morning
person or a night person?
- If I didn't have to wake up early,
I'd be naturally a night person.
I grab the phone, and I never lay in bed.
I'm up, I grab the phone,
I go get a drink of water
or go to the bathroom,
I'm usually, after I wake up,
I'm out of bed within seconds.
Usually because I try to
maximize sleep, so, I gotta go.
I've gone to the extreme of,
I've got a workout in four minutes,
like, I've gotta go to the
bathroom, brush my teeth,
put on gym clothes and get downstairs.
I keep it tight.
I would naturally be a night person.
I like to get work done at
midnight, one, two, three.
I don't like the morning.
I wake up way earlier than I used to.
There was a time when I was
such an extreme night person,
building Wine Library and go
to sleep at three or four,
and not get into Wine
Library until eleven.
That happened for, like, a year.
That's how extreme I went.
But now I get up at six or
seven, and that's how I roll.
- [Jen] Okay.
I also wanna ask you,
we get the sense, all the
people who love and adore you,
and maybe the people, even, who don't,
that we really know you because
you know, you're everywhere.
I really do feel like we do
know you, to some degree.
- You do, yes.
- [Jen] What would we be
surprised to know about you?
- Well, you know nothing about my family,
you don't know anything
about my family life.
- [Jen] That's true, you
really don't talk about that.
- No, I mean, like, nothing
about my kids or my wife.
I spend very little on that.
We keep that private, so you
guys don't know that part.
I mean, I think the part that most people
don't know about me is all of you,
anybody that likes or dislikes
me, but more likes me,
has to keep a percentage to themselves
to keep them protected from me
not letting them down, right?
When someone admires or likes somebody,
there's a protective
mechanism that everyone has,
which is, "Man, I really hope
he's like that in real life."
It's been really, really,
Gavin, what about you?
That happened, right?
- [Gavin] I wasn't paying attention.
- Did you, when you first
started working here,
there was a part of you like,
"Oh, I hope he's that real
in real life," like, right?
And you didn't have the same dynamic,
'cause I was in a different place.
Nonetheless, I think the biggest thing
that people don't know about me
is that I think I'm even nicer
in real life than I project.
You agree, right?
- [Gavin] I mean, 'cause
I see you every day.
- Right, 'cause you see the
real stuff that I can't show
where I'm being really nice,
but it's inappropriate for me to show it,
'cause it may make the other
person look a little weird.
- [Jen] Well, that's
like the perfect lead-in
to this question that
I'm dying to ask you,
or just, I want to mention,
because it really,
I saw this the other day where you said
that you're in this unique position
where you have crossed the chasm into
being cool for the younger people.
My 17-year-old son is
you know, completely--
- He agrees.
- [Jen] Hangs on your every word.
I have to quote it exactly,
because it was so good.
You said, "If I can achieve
making self-awareness
"and patience and gratitude and empathy
"cool characteristics of an alpha male,
"I will have made a real impact."
And I thought, God, that is, like,
for all of the moms and dads
that are probably so mad at you
that their kids are changing
their minds about college,
you probably get just as
many love letters or more
after a statement like that.
But then, I'm, like,
can we really do that?
What would it take to really
make those things cool
without it just being, like, a good quote,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah, I mean, I think I'm doing it.
With me, my quotes come after
I've already done something.
I would have never had the audacity
to say something that ludicrous
if I hadn't started seeing
it actually start to happen.
- [Jen] It's amazing, it's amazing.
- It is amazing.
I really think it's very special
when somebody comes along
and is a great communicator
and can move people's
minds and does it for good.
'Cause some do it for
good, some do it for bad,
and some never realize they can do it.
Think about how excited I am
about both your 17-year-old son and you.
For your 17-year-old son,
I'm gonna create a new paradigm of cool,
and hopefully that will work.
And for you,
I inspired you to do,
and now you're finding out
something that you're doing
that you enjoy and you may be good at it.
That's incredible.
- [Jen] Yeah, thank you.
- It's cool, listen.
I talk about it as if it's
not even me living it,
because it's almost too
heady for me to, like,
I'm being serious right now.
I try not to overthink it
because it becomes a little daunting
if you realize you're sitting
on a superpower, right?
I try to
take it for what it is.
The truth is, I actually
think it's a bigger indication
of my parents and my
environment than it is on me,
so I don't get big-headed about it.
I know my intent is to do the best I can.
I don't feel daunted
by the responsibility,
I don't feel like it's my,
I don't think I'm that special,
that I have to change the world.
But, I'm more than interested in trying.
- [Jen] (laughs) I love it.
I would imagine that,
if you did think about it too hard,
it would get kind of like, scary,
or, I don't know, maybe it
would feel like a burden?
You say that, I mean,
and you teach us to,
really, we just should care
immensely about everything,
but not give a crap about what people say.
But I wonder, don't you
ever get your feelings hurt?
- I get my feelings hurt every day.
- [Jen] What's that?
- I get my feelings hurt every
day in, like, a fake way.
I'm a human,
I'm just not very emotional
when it comes to this
because I understand the score.
I'm unbelievably emotional,
I'm completely unemotional.
I think I have this great balance
that's coming from
extreme characteristics.
I mean,
there was a engagement
I had today on Twitter
where two guys in Europe
or somewhere not in the US,
I kinda quickly glanced,
who I think were from
the advertising industry
were making fun of me.
Like, one of 'em put a
picture of me where it says,
"Hustle your fuckin' face off,"
and he said something
to the degree of like,
"This is an actual quote.
"Can you fuckin' believe this guy?"
And his buddy, or a similar-thinking
guy jumped in and said,
I think he said, "Try to find a quote
"that's more ludicrous
than this kind of thing."
And then his buddy found one,
but I don't think that
one was a real quote,
'cause the other one was real.
But they just took a picture of me
and put some ridiculous
quote that I think I did say.
Bottom line is, they were bantering.
I jump in because my feelings are hurt,
'cause I don't know,
I want these two guys to like
me, not think I'm a douchebag.
I reply with my true
feeling, which is like,
"Yo, guys, can you stop creating ammo
"for my friends to make fun of me with?"
And, "I wish you good health,
"I hope we get to share a glass of wine,"
'cause I notice one guy's from Australia,
I like Australian wines.
I was answering one of the guys,
and then I got to the office
and I didn't see if the
other guy was engaged.
One guy jumped in and said,
"Touche," or "Fair enough,
"if you're ever in Australia,
let's grab that glass,"
and I loved it, because, like,
it's less that my feelings are hurt,
it's that I respect
everybody else's opinions
no matter who they are,
even within my own success.
I think I'm gonna be all-time,
yet I don't believe that your
or your 17-year-old son's,
or those two guys's opinions
are any less valuable than mine.
I just think my ultimate
superpower is empathy,
at the highest level.
I think I'm so empathetic
that everything else I
am is almost secondary,
even though I have a lot of
other strong characteristics,
strengths and weaknesses.
Of course, my feelings are hurt,
'cause I'm so empathetic,
yet I'm so self-aware and confident
that it's not able to fully
penetrate and become a negative.
I think it becomes a positive,
because I know how to calibrate
the pushback or the name-calling.
- [Jen] Obviously--
- That was a good articulation.
- [Jen] Some empathy and
you were born with that,
and then the other part
is you had great parents.
- And great circumstance, right?
I lost a lot as a kid.
I didn't speak the language.
We had no money.
I wasn't a great athlete.
I was a terrible student.
I've lived my first 18 years
of my life as a fucking loser,
which made the next fucking
100 years super easy
because I wasn't scared of losing.
A lot of kids are coddled,
overloved, eighth-place trophies.
And no one loved, actually
believed, that's not true.
Let me start again.
A lot of people were coddled.
A lot of people are eighth-place trophies.
A lot of people didn't deal with adversity
because they figured out
how to run the school model
and were straight-A students,
gifted with talent in sports.
And so they were winning
their first 18 years,
so when they go into real
life with inevitable losses,
especially for somebody
who pandered to the system,
which means they then
go work in a corporation
where they have no control
and merit doesn't ride,
I'm the reverse.
- [Jen] You said you were
a loser the first 18 years,
but I have the sense
that you were probably
a popular kid in school.
Very.
- Were you?
- [Gary] Yes, I was super,
and that part has never gone away.
I was popular for, you
know, I have charisma,
so that's always good.
I was popular because I was super nice.
Nice has been,
you know, over the last week or two,
I have started pushing kindness and nice.
It's funny.
I feel like, almost just like
I figured out my back was hurt
after figuring my adductor
was hurt, and my knee,
and my neck, and my shoulder,
I feel like I'm just going through my life
and discovering, wait a
minute, it's not just hustle!
Wait a minute, it's not just sales!
Wait a minute, it's not just empathy!
I feel like somewhere literally
within the last 10 days,
I'm like, "Huh,
"kindness is probably a real big reason
"this is all working out for me."
And so, in school, my kindness was amazing
'cause I was so self-confident
that I wasn't willing to make fun of kids
when that's what the cool kids did.
That, in a weird way, over time,
made me quite popular
with a lot of people.
- [Jen] Oh, my God,
I just thought of the
name of your new book.
It's Crush It With Kindness.
Instead of Kill 'Em With Kindness,
Crush it With Kindness, that's it.
Just send me, like 1%, that's all I need.
- I think kindness
is something that I will
continue to tap into this year.
This will be the Year of
Kindness in my content.
I can feel it.
I'm excited about that because
self-awareness and gratitude
and work ethic and honor,
I think, is something that an alpha male
can kind of like get there to.
Kindness, being sweet, being a sweetheart,
is just not necessarily
the thing that I think people
naturally gravitate towards,
and it's funny.
My public persona,
AKA, when I do interviews and speeches,
I wouldn't say is filled with kindness.
I'm my most combative and competitive.
It's that my real life
is so filled with kindness and sweetness,
and I think it's going
to be interesting to see
how I tap into this and
how I articulate it.
- [Jen] Oh, wow.
I just can't wait to see where this goes.
I think that's amazing.
And it's funny,
because the other challenger,
James Altucher, when he came on the show,
I asked him,
"Have you had situations where
"you've interviewed
people who are winners,
"or they're these big guys
who are really, like, jerks?"
And he said, "You know, not really.
"One or two," he said,
"But the truth is, people
don't get that far, usually,
"by being super-jerks."
- And definitely not people
who are playing
in a game that is based on merit,
like entrepreneurship, right?
It's a little bit easier to
navigate through corporate,
which is a lot of what we're
seeing now in the world,
because you can be protected,
'cause the market isn't fair.
It's hedged by the tastemakers
and the gatekeepers.
The more entrepreneurial,
the more fair it is, to James's point,
the more likely you have
to be a decent person.
And definitely if you wanna
build something really big,
for the long haul.
I'm trying to build an
absolute business empire
and be admired.
That is a very
zero-sum game.
Either you are kind and
talented, or you're not.
- [Jen] Who would it mean the most to you,
besides your parents and
your kids and everybody,
who would it mean the most
for you to be admired by?
I mean, like, anyone specifically
that you've got filed away
that you're like, yeah?
- Probably Brandon Warnke,
he runs Wine Library.
He's my best friend.
To me, it's very simple.
I wanna be admired by the
people that know me the best,
because they actually know the truth.
It's super more important
to me that Tyler and Tyler,
who are sitting across from me right now,
my ad man and one of the
guy's who's on my contact team
who films me often.
It's much more important to me
that they blindly think I'm the best
than an employee at Vayner
that's not interacting with me
more than once or twice a year,
because they know.
- [Jen] I was watching you
walk through your office,
and all those, I guess
hundreds of employees,
and I thought, because you are your brand
and because you are such a strong brand
and because people gravitate to you,
I'm sure that's one of
the big selling points,
that they wanna come and work for you.
But not everybody can
get that access to you,
so I bet that's a huge challenge for you
to figure out how you're
gonna divvy up Gary.
All those people-
- Yes and no.
I think that a lot of them actually
wanna just work at a great agency, and
haven't gotten into,
there's some people that are
even weirdly, not oblivious,
but really don't know the extent
of what's happening out there
with my life in that realm,
and that's great, because
I'll be honest with you.
I associate much more
to Gary Vaynerchuk, the CEO
of VaynerX, VaynerMedia,
than I do as GaryVee.
I associate more to being Gary Vaynerchuk,
the guy behind the strategy
of GaryVee, than GaryVee.
And look, GaryVee is me.
It's my energy when I'm
trying to talk to the world.
But most of my life is spent
not talking to the world.
I do the best I can.
I mean, I think that's
just important as a CEO,
let alone as a personality.
I think the people that are
most bought into me, fans,
get their way into spending time with me
because they can't hold out, right?
They ask for the meeting, they
hover around, they hang out.
Or some just kind of wait
and wait for their moment,
but again, it's not
something I kill myself with.
- [Jen] I'm a marketer in
a sea of digital marketers.
I think I'm special,
I think that I'm a favorite
because of the level of
service and care and love
that I give to the people
who are in my orbit.
But
I'm not niched down.
I do know the value of it.
I wish so badly that I could find a niche.
Do you think that it's--
- No.
You're, you're, you're, you're--
- [Jen] I don't wanna
do just, like, lawyers.
- Your niche is you.
I'm not niche, my niche is that it's me,
and my perspective and my efforts and me.
There's nothing more niche
than being the human being.
- [Jen] Okay, that's awesome.